[Applause]
whoa oh my God
guys oh my gosh um
this is so unbelievable I could scream
um thank you to our 007 family Barbara
broccoli Michael G Wilson
um MGM Carrie fukunaga Daniel Craig to
Han Zimmer who's not here but is so
amazing Stephen Lipson Johnny Mar for
for taking our song and making it worthy
of James Bond our managers Danny Brandon
and Laura we love you so much
[Applause]
um and thank you to Tony Seiler we love
you
lastly we want to thank our parents who
have always been our biggest
Inspirations and our heroes and we love
you as parents and we love you as real
people too
um
thank you so much to the academy and we
promise not to lose these
[Applause]